what's cracking be welcome back to thug
notes this week we keepin it classy were
Pride and Prejudice by Jane Austen this
book tells the story of Elizabeth Bennet
and her five sisters
now mama better be trying to get them
girls to strut their stuff in order to
find some husbands one day to her rich
cats named Bingley and Darcy rollin the
town now mama better be geeked up trying
to sling Jane in front of that boy
Bingley look I ain't saying she a gold
digger but Bingley sure as hell ain't no
brother so Jane gets all dolled up and
tears it up with Bingley up in the club
same night let's try to kick it with
Darcy but that hook he's straight disses
her said she ain't flying up the road
with his crew shortly after a rich
preacher man named Collins and a
smooth-talking soldier boy named Wickham
drop into High let them Bennet girls
Wickham tells Lizzie that he got beef
with that fool Darcy over some cash
Darcy be on him couple days later
JB straight trippin cuz Bingley peaced
out of town with no explanation
then one day Lizzy runs it to that punk
Darcy and discovers he was the one that
went up to Bingley and said yo shorty
don't marry that trick Jane oh snap
then Darcy the confessed his love to Liz
but my girl B are like hell naw blood
you can't block my sister then Darcy
says Liz a letter saying that his beef
with Wickham it's cuz that player tried
to marry his sister in order to get some
of that old money not only that but he
only told Bingley to drop Jane cuz he
thought she wasn't feeling it later
Lizzy finds out that her baby sister
Lydia been seduced by Wickham and run
away with that player now that Wickham
that jacked up Lydia's reputation he
gonna marry her only if the Bennett's
pay him to do it damn
so homeboy Darcy straight up comes to
the rescue and pays Wickham to marry
Lydia
after list finds out that it was Darcy
that saved her sister from dirty skank
status Lizzy straight up Falls for this
honky good thing for her Bingley soon
realizes that Jane really is the foxiest
ho on the hood so Bingley brains his age
Darcy to the Bennett's place immense
he's been acting a fool
Mary's J then my man Darcy proposes the
Liz and they get married happy ending
for all the white girls
all the bad is catching the hood know
that the opening sentence of this book
is one of the most important in all of
literature it is a truth universally
acknowledged that a single man in
possession of a good fortune must be in
want of a wife now you might be thinking
is this real talk right here or is it
Jane Austen just playing when she throw
our big-ass terms like universal truth
that's exactly the kind of irony Austen
be slinging all up in this [ __ ]
for example on one hand Liz shacking up
with that rich playboy Darcy supports
all of them hierarchical anti-feminists
traditions but on the other hand my girl
Liz ain't acting like society's [ __ ]
nah nah she says up the establishment
and be active strong-willed independent
and don't take no lip from that boy
Darcy now that's some kind of woman so
the truth is my girl Jane Austen don't
play his strengths
she'd be slinging irony all day her day
making this book liable for all kinds of
opposing interpretations you'll pick
these themes blood moral blindness and
self-knowledge early on Darcy's pride
made him think that Lizzie would get got
at the chance to marry him cuz he got
swirled pockets and she ain't none but
also Lizzie's prejudiced make her jumpin
some wack-ass conclusion after Wickham
tells her about his beef with Darcy but
after Liz rejects Darcy and he says her
the letter explaining how things really
beat these fools realize how their pride
in presidents be clouding their moral
judgment homeboy yo if you want to talk
central team up in here listen good
traditional society be full of egos
class structures social laws economics
always be putting distance between
people so what Austin may be asking is
how do the people gonna come together in
the world of such distances playing hey
thanks for watching third notes make
sure you add subscribe and I'll see you
next week player
[Music]